it what are what are some of the
struggles that you have to overcome
um i don't know like sometimes like
i hate comparing myself to other comics
or i'll see a comic selling more tickets
to me and i'm like ah
wow but i i i've learned to like take a
step back
i don't for one i don't run to social
media if i have an issue with something
or i'm going through something
i go okay is it worth it to really post
this because
i've realized a lot of things are in
your own head well
i'll give you an example um when we were
shooting the first think like a man
uh you know kev's he's the top dog
stand-ups right
so he invited he invited all the guys
out to come see him at the laugh factory
jerry romney elian terrance
but i didn't get invited so we go to set
monday and everybody's talking about
last night at the laugh factory and i'm
going
what and they all got pictures on like
twitter and stuff
and i'm like i did what and then
somebody said gary why did you go
i go i didn't know anything about it and
then
kev literally just goes you ever feel
like an sometimes
but i think it was just i'm a comedian
and he just assumed i would know about
it or i just hang out at comedy clubs it
wasn't personal
but in the home and i found out i was
like dang
what's wrong with me you know what i
mean here i am a grown man
worried about what some other dude is
talking about and feeling left out
when i really shouldn't have it really
wasn't a big deal it was just one of
those things probably out of sight out
of mind
ah yeah i probably should invite you but
but it was a lot of it was in my brain
too
yeah that's i think that's good for
comics to hear though that even someone
at your level
even has to deal with all right stop
comparing myself to someone else
or like well this isn't some conspiracy
to hold me down this was just
circumstance like even someone at your
level still has to remind themselves of
those realities
and i would tell comics too like don't
rush to social media
if you feel like you have somebody's
having an issue with you you have an
issue with them
i know because i've said it numerous
times in the past you don't know what's
going on behind closed doors with these
studios and networks and your name
can be getting tossed around and then
you say something about somebody
attached to that film and all of a
sudden
you're not in the running anymore it's
like man
i've seen it happen a few times i'm not
gonna say names but i've seen people
like
we were about to hire this person and
we're like
don't deal with that dang but even like
you for think like a man
didn't they cut you out of the movie
poster weren't you like
they kind of that was that wasn't they
kind of kind of they kind of squeegeed
you out of a few things is that
no that was funny it's almost funny it's
funny now
um because my manager was really upset
and i didn't really sell a poster really
she goes you're not gonna believe this
and i was like what and then uh and so
will packer the producer called me and
said i heard you're upset i go i don't i
don't
even seen it and then he goes oh
he said well let me tell you the the
process we were doing we wanted all
couples
and then of course kevin we never really
met your wife in the first one
so i i wasn't tripping yeah i really
it's almost like a joke now every time
somebody post it i'll splice myself in
but in the end you're in the movie
nobody really remembers the poster
you're in the movie
right yeah but and then honestly
uh my part was probably the smallest of
all the guy characters the core six
because you never got to see my
relationship until the second one mm-hmm
so i i literally i was watching the
movie and i think i
i don't know why i tied it one time i
literally disappeared for 38 minutes
of the film like you timed it
i'm
that's hilarious thanks for watching hot
breath the verse
if you want to support the show go join
our patreon but if you don't like
supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click the watch more videos to
keep us alive
in the algorithm